at this time we found no evidence no
evidence to suggest anybody else was
involved in this attack however we're
still making extensive inquiries to
ensure that no one else was involved our
investigative priority at this time is
to ensure that there is no one related
as an outstanding threat to the public
to this end we carried out two searches
that addresses both in Staffordshire and
in the stoke-on-trent area our officers
have therefore been supported by
officers from Staffordshire and the West
Midlands counterterrorism police I would
like to thank them as well as the local
community in those areas for the support
they've shown as we carry out those
crucial inquiries the investigation team
is also speakings of many of those who
were present at fishmongers hall we now
know this attack began inside
fishmongers hall just before 2 p.m.
yesterday
the attacker whose identity we confirmed
last night
stabbed a number of people inside the
building and as a result five people
have suffered injuries three people a
man and two women were injured and
remained in hospital their families have
been contacted and specialist offices
are supporting them tragically two
people a man and a woman were killed
during the attack and of course I'm
fully aware that the media and social
media have named one of those victims
you must understand that I have to wait
for formal identification from the
coroner but I will provide you an update
as soon as I can on behalf of the entire
policing family can I offer my heartfelt
thoughts and condolences to those
families of the victims both the
deceased and those still in hospital and
everyone who has been affected by this
incident I've said we've searched two
addresses enquiries go on but at this
point in time there is no intelligence
to suggest anyone else was involved and
at this stage we are considering that he
was the attacker in this case
as a precaution we have enhanced police
patrols across London of both armed and
unarmed officers and the public can
expect to see an increased police
presence throughout the weekend as
colleagues from the Met City of London
and British Transport Police carry out
those patrols
you